sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden diese bauten aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
nur ein fernes echo hallt noch von den
menschen die hier einst lebten und
arbeiteten
was bleibt sind offene fragen und
ungelöste rätsel
warum wurden prestige reiche
straßenprojekte unbefahrbar und wie kam
es dass italiens schicksal im ersten
weltkrieg von einer mehrere kilometer
langen schotterpiste mit 52 tunneln
abhängen die italienische soldaten
1917 unter lebensgefahr den alpen
abtrotzten
die straße wurde in nur neun monaten
gebaut in großer höhe mit wenigen
mitteln unter beschuss sie rettete am
ende 1000 in das leben
welche fehler führten zum schlimmsten
straßen auf jasko großbritanniens
[Musik]
diese straße zeigt uns dass die dinge so
richtig schief laufen können das merkt
man sich
[Musik]
warum wurde eine der größten
touristenattraktionen frankreichs für
die öffentlichkeit gesperrt
die erbauer der grafschaften etwas das
sie selbst nicht für möglich gehalten
hätten die leute waren ganz scharf
darauf diese hoch romantische straße zu
befahren
[Musik]
und was brachte einen amerikanischen
geschäftsmann dazu eine höchsten straße
aus holz zu bauen
ein schönes beispiel für die kühnheit
der amerikaner eine straße mitten durch
die wüste bauen klar warum nicht kein
problem
[Musik]
wir nutzen sie jeden tag und halten sie
für selbstverständlich straßen spielen
eine wichtige rolle für handeln verkehr
und kommunikation
doch manchmal geht es beim bau einer
straße nicht nur um wirtschaftliche
aspekte sondern um leben und tod
[Musik]
von der fertigstellung dieser
militärstrasse in den dolomiten hing
sogar das schicksal einer ganzen nation
ab
der monte carasso biotronik mehr als
2200 meter hoch in den norditalienischen
alpen nahe des gardasees
durch die steilen felsen zieht sich ein
netz aus tunneln wegen und besseren
zeiten fahren
das ist die berühmte strada del
cinquanta die galerie die straße der 52
tunnel deshalb wurde sie im ersten
weltkrieg so existenziell wichtig
die situation war damals sehr angespannt
für die menschen war der druck immens
die ingenieure haben damals unmögliches
geleistet sie bauten dieser straße in
nur neun monaten sieht und das in dieser
höhe
die note verlieh ihnen flügel sie zogen
alles viel schneller durch als zu
friedlich zeiten
es war eine erstaunliche
ingenieursleistung und sollte auch als
solcher anerkannt werden
italien tritt erst 1915 in den ersten
weltkrieg ein auf seiten der hong kong
und erklärt österreich ungarn den krieg
die gefechte finden nicht wie im rest
europas in schlammigen schützengräben
statt sondern auf eisigen gipfeln
[Musik]
die front verlief in den bergen an der
grenze zu österreich ungarn gekämpft
wurde oberhalb der schneegrenze weshalb
vom so genannten weißen krieg die rede
war das brachte enorme logistische
herausforderungen mit sich
truppenbewegungen waren dort oben kaum
möglich deshalb gab es eigentlich für
beide seiten nicht viel zu gewinnen
die italienischen und österreichischen
truppen liefern sich einen erbitterten
stellungskrieg sich tausende soldaten
sterben viele erfrieren in der kargen
dachlandschaft oder werden von lawinen
verschüttet
1916 besetzen die österreicher zwei
nachbar gipfel des monte paschi mio
damit ist der weg nach venedig fast frei
manuel garate war früher ein alpino ein
italienischer gebirgsjäger er kennt sich
bestens aus mit den schlachten wie hier
geschlagen worden
[Musik]
dieser berg markiert das ende der
venezianischen ebene und den beginn der
alpen während die österreicher hier
durchgekommen hätten sie bis zur ebene
vordringen und venedig unter ihre
kontrolle bringen können
bis 1916 verlief die front im
wesentlichen entlang des sonst so einem
fluss in nordost italien
danach verlagerte sich das geschehen
nach westen richtung trentino
als den österreichern in der sogenannten
südtirol offensive der durchbruch gelang
wurden die berge am rand der
venezianischen ebene plötzlich
strategisch bedeutsam
von den erhöhten stellungen aus haben
die österreicher gute sicht auf die
bisher einzige straße die zum gipfel des
passo bio führt und außerdem in
schussweite liegt
da oben in den bergen kämpften eine
million soldaten 600 tausend italiener
gegen 400.000 österreicher die
österreicher kamen von dort nachdem sie
den berg dort drüben eingenommen hatten
konnten die italienischen soldaten den
weg hier drüben nicht mehr nutzen
deshalb wurde die straße der 52 tunnel
gebaut
denn die italiener brauchen dringend
eine neue versorgungsroute um ihre
stellungen auf dem monte bio sicher mit
kriegsgerät soldaten und vorräten zu
versorgen sonst können sie den druck der
österreicher nicht mehr lange
standhalten eine straße muss in die
steilen felswände geschlagen werden auf
der abgewandten seite des berges
in kriegszeiten müssen ingenieure
unmögliches möglich machen den satz das
geht nicht gibt's in so einer situation
nicht es ist kein zufall dass die
größten technischen fortschritte unter
genau solchen umständen gemacht wurden
die straße der 52 tunnel ist eine wahre
meisterleistung der ingenieurskunst
sie wird viel zu wenig als solche
gewürdigt
mit ungeheurem aufwand legen
italienische soldaten eine neue
schotterpiste an meist gerade mal breit
genug für zwei tiere die zerlegtes
tricks gerät munition und vorräte
transportieren
wer hier vom weg abkommt stutzt in den
sicheren tod teile der strecke müssen in
und durch die felsen gehauen werden
die ingenieure unterteilten die strecke
in abschnitte der anfang lag auf 1200
metern das ende in fast 2000 metern höhe
stück für stück wurden sie miteinander
verbunden
für die arbeit werden soll daten
herangezogen
die meisten von ihnen sind steinhauer
und bergarbeiter die für den einsatz an
der front schon zu alt sind ihr feind
ist der berg
wo es keine geeigneten felsvorsprünge
gibt müssen sie tunnel graben insgesamt
52 stück
sie waren nur dem namen nach soldaten
befanden sich aber in umkämpften gebiet
denn die tatsache dass die
österreichische artillerie die
ursprüngliche versorgungs straße auf den
monte pasu bio unter beschuss genommen
hatte war ja genau der grund warum eine
neue geschützte route auf den berg
gebraucht wurde
was für eine logistische herausforderung
das war die straße entlang zu laufen ist
schon ein wahres abenteuer wie
gefährlich muss es erst gewesen sein sie
zu bauen diese männer verdienen
bewunderung für ihre arbeit
wahrscheinlich haben sie keine orden
bekommen aber verdient hätten sie es
die italiener stehen unter enormen
zeitdruck können sie die straße vor dem
nächsten österreichischen angriff
fertigstellen ihr größter alliierter
hier oben ist der presslufthammer
[Musik]
presslufthammer kamen ab mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts zum einsatz
plötzlich war es viel einfacher tunnel
und straßen zu bauen bis dahin mussten
felsen mühsam mit hammer meißel
traktiert werden um das gestein
abzutragen oder um löcher für den
sprengstoff reinzuhauen
damit lässt sich schnell und effektiv
arbeiten
die männer arbeiteten entlang der
felswände wo es hunderte meter tief in
den abgrund ging und versuchten dem berg
einen schmalen pfad abzuringen auf dem
gerade mal zwei altäre nebeneinander
platz hatten ohne ihr werk wäre eine
militärische niederlage kaum noch
abzuwenden gewesen darum musste diese
straße einfach gebaut werden
die zeit war ein wesentlicher faktor und
der presslufthammer macht es möglich
schnell und effektiv zu arbeiten
entwicklung
[Musik]
sie wurden tiefe löcher in den fels und
sprengen sich den weg frei
in den tunneln kann man heute noch
solche löcher finden der sprengstoff
machte den bau der tunnel erst möglich
die arbeiten an der sechseinhalb
kilometer langen strecke dauern von
februar bis november
1917 um zeit zu sparen lässt man es
meist bei sehr schmalen wegen auch da wo
es steil in die tiefe geht wird auf
schutzgeländer verzichtet
am ende stellt sich die frage ob der weg
seinem zweck überhaupt erfüllen kann
oder ob die benutzung viel zu gefährlich
ist
die straße wurde in neun monaten gebaut
in großer höhe mit wenigen mitteln unter
härtesten bedingungen
sie rettete tausenden das leben
[Musik]
die straße der 52 tunnel versorgt die
italiener mit lebenswichtigem nachschub
nur so können sie ihre stellungen halten
1918 gelingt es ihnen schließlich die
österreicher zurückzudrängen
nach dem krieg geräte eben noch so
wichtige strategische lebensretter auf
den monte bio in vergessenheit fels
lawinen machen tunnel und wege zum teil
unpassierbar
nur noch dach wanderer dürfen den weg
heutzutage nutzen
entlang der route gibt es einige male
die an die heroischen leistungen der
bauarbeiter erinnern
[Musik]
sie haben in so kurzer zeit so viel
geschafft den verzierten eingangs bogen
mit dem selbst gewählten motto haben sie
sich redlich verdient
wieder steht
experte um nomen das heißt so viel wie
die namen derer die großes vollbringen
werden für immer in erinnerung bleiben
[Musik]
von den italienischen hinüber in die
französischen alpen genauer gesagt in
die berge oberhalb von grenoble
auch hier wurde den felsen eine straße
abgetrotzt allerdings nicht zu
kriegszwecken sondern um abgelegenen
bergdörfern den handel mit anderen
teilen des landes zu ermöglichen
die straße legen goalie auch bekannt als
der große engpass war bald im ganzen
land bekannt
warum aber ist ein solches meisterwerk
der ingenieurskunst heute nicht mehr
zugänglich und sogar dem verfall
preisgegeben und wir haben es ingenieure
geschafft hier überhaupt eine straße in
die felsen zu hauen
die erbauer der gran coupé vollbrachten
etwas das ihre eigenen erwartungen
übertraf
die gründe sind ein schönes beispiel für
den sieg dass menschen über die natur
die strecke ist absolut einzigartig
da gibt es alles stelle gipfel felsnasen
verschiedene untergründe die wasserläufe
schneiden schluchten ins gebirge
an so einer stelle straßen und tunnel zu
bauen ist extrem schwierig die
grundschule wurden vor 150 jahren mit
einfachsten mitteln gebaut was für eine
leistung
[Musik]
weit oberhalb des zusammenschlusses von
lieser und hohen erstreckt sich das werk
uhr plateau
wegen seiner steilen klippen war es
jahrhundertelang vom rest der welt
abgeschnitten
mitte des 19 jahrhunderts fordern die
hier lebenden menschen den bau einer
straße
sie wollen endlich hinunter zu den
märkten im tal aber es gibt gewaltige
hindernisse
[Musik]
umgeben von den felsen und steigern
schluchten gleich das plateau einer
festung
da durchzukommen ist keine leichte
aufgabe
die straßenbahn ag ad hoc und jean-marc
lohnt sind vom fach und können
einschätzen wie schwierig und gefährlich
das projekt gewesen sein muss
es war praktisch unmöglich
ein wahres jahrhundertprojekt für unsere
region
das werk oktober völlig isoliert die
leute lebten ihren wald während sich
unten in noja der handel abspielte dank
der straße konnten endlich waren hin und
her transportiert werden die leute
ritten auf pferden oder maultieren
runter ins tal
die straße wurde wirklich dringend
gebraucht
[Musik]
im lauf der jahrtausende hat der berg
fluss werden es um eine tiefe schlucht
ausgewaschen
entlang dieser route eine straße zu
bauen ist leichter gesagt als getan
die strecke folgt zunächst den spuren
der natürliche erosion
wasser sucht sich immer den weg des
geringsten widerstands insofern ist es
keine schlechte idee sich am wasserlauf
zu orientieren andererseits wenn das
wasser hier auf dem geringsten
widerstand trifft wie es dann wohl der
untergrund beschaffen schwer zu sagen ob
es die richtige entscheidung war
andererseits hat die straße ja lange
gehalten
die arbeiten für die straße beginnen
parallel zum fluss lauf wird ein tunnel
angelegt doch nach einigen hundert
metern fällt der fluss plötzlich steil
ab den ingenieuren bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als eine straße mitten in die
steile felswand zu hauen
über und neben diesem felsen aber auf
der anderen seite geht es steil bergab
es ist quasi ein offener tun
die arbeiter entwickeln eine technik die
geradezu selbstmörderisch anmutet sie
seien sich an der felswand ab mai sollen
ein loch für den sprengstoff zünden die
lunte an und schwingen sich zur seite
eine extrem gefährliche methode
hätte es damals bessere alternativen
gegeben schwer zu sagen sie hätten den
felsen auch mit spitzhacken und äxten
bearbeiten können doch das hätte noch
viel länger gedauert deshalb wählten sie
wohl die gefährlichere option
heutzutage würde jeder arbeitsschutz
beauftragte schweißausbrüche kriegen
diese männer setzten jeden tag ihr leben
aufs spiel
[Musik]
nach fast elf jahren bauzeit können 1854
die ersten fuhrwerke die rund drei
kilometer lange strecke befahren die
neue straße bringt dramatische
veränderungen für die bewohner der
region mit sich
plötzlich einfach zu erreichen mausert
sich der atemberaubend schönen
landstrich zu einem beliebten
ausflugsziel in den französischen alpen
[Musik]
juli waren ursprünglich als
handelsstraße geplant die bergdörfer
sollten mit dem rest der welt verbunden
werden
die nerven aufreibenden bauarbeiten
verschafften der straße schnell ein
romantisches image die strecke war etwas
ganz besonderes und die leute waren
richtig scharf darauf sie zu befahren
ich weiß nicht ob den erbauern klar war
dass sie ein künstlerisches meisterwerk
geschaffen hatten
die große route ist wunderschön und
geheimnisvoll und das ist es doch was
große ingenieurskunst ausmacht
aber mit zunehmendem verkehr und
größeren fahrzeugen beginnen die
probleme
als im 20 jahrhundert autos lkw und
busse die pferde wagen ablösen kommt die
enge bergstraße schnell an ihre grenzen
und sie zu verbreitern gilt nicht so
ohne weiteres
die große strecke ist ziemlich schmal
und das hat ja auch seine gründe die
decken und die wände in den tunneln
wurden nicht extra verstärkt auch nicht
in den halboffenen passagen
bleibt nur sehr wenig spielraum um die
straße zu verbreitern
eine verbreiterung wäre eine große
herausforderung gewesen wie hätte man
die felsen abstützen sollen welche art
von stützkonstruktionen wären nötig
gewesen besonders in den tunneln wie
sich vor steinschlag schützen
für die damalige zeit war die lösung
solcher fragen wohl doch etwas zu
anspruchsvoll
[Musik]
für größere und schnellere autos werden
die engen kurven immer wieder zu
todesfällen
[Musik]
zur jahrtausendwende schlägt dann die
natur zu große feld segmente brechen ab
und begraben teile der straße unter sich
[Musik]
an dieser stelle kam es 2000 um 2005 zu
schweren steinschlägen
der erste ging links von uns nieder der
zweite hier direkt über uns
im jahr 2005 wird die straße nach gut
150 jahren betrieb komplett gesperrt
vielleicht hätte es ja lösungen für die
probleme gegeben zb das gestein so zu
befestigen dass es nicht mehr auf die
straße fällt aber das wäre ein radikaler
eingriff in die natur gewesen
vielleicht gäbe es dann kein risiko mehr
aber auch keine natürliche schönheit
so sehe ich es auch persönlich bedauere
die strecke nicht mehr befahren zu
können ist es wohl besser so sie ist
einfach zu gefährlich
[Musik]
auf festem untergrund lässt sich überall
eine straße bauen doch was tun wenn der
boden ein eigenleben führt im norden
englands unweit eines hügels namens
motor liegt eine straße die von der
natur ruiniert wurde wie kaum eine
andere auf den britischen inseln
die mentor roth wurde im 19 jahrhundert
in da bisher gebaut heute sieht sie aus
als hätte ein erdbeben sie auseinander
gerissen was genau ist dort passiert
ich weiß nicht auf welchem stand die
geologie war als die straße am mentor
gebaut wurde jedenfalls sieht man dort
spuren eines erdrutsches
dieser fall zeigt uns dass die dinge so
richtig schief laufen können das sollte
man sich gut merken
die bauarbeiten für die straße beginnen
1819 das dorf castleton das nahe einer
blei mine liegt sollen mit der straße
richtung verfehlt wirtschaftlich besser
angebunden werden
[Musik]
während der industriellen revolution
schossen überall in großbritannien
fabriken aus dem boden und für den
warenverkehr brauchten sie dringend eine
gute infrastruktur
ohne ein netzwerk aus neuen straßenbahn
linien und kanälen die das ganze land
miteinander verbanden hätte die
industrielle revolution so wie wir sie
kennen nicht stattfinden können
diese verkehrswege waren die adern durch
die das blut der industriellen
revolution gepumpt wurde sie bedingen
einander
[Musik]
doch es gibt ein problem
der kürzeste weg für die straße müsste
eine relativ steilen hügelkette queren
würde man sie dort entlang führen wäre
sie zu steil für die damals gängigen
pferde wagen
ein pferd kann einen schwer beladenen
wagen nur bis zu einer gewissen steigung
die straße hoch zum
mentor war dahingehend günstiger
beschaffen der hang war nicht zu steil
dort kam die pferde gut hoch
also wurde die straße dort
aber die leute damals ahnten nicht dass
sie sich für den ungeeigneten ort
überhaupt entschieden
die neue straße wird unterhalb des bergs
mentor gebaut der seitliche hang ist
nicht besonders steil
hier kann die straße in sanften kurven
verlaufen auf und abstieg sind nicht
besonders schwer
[Musik]
den hang mit seiner außergewöhnlichen
geologischen beschaffenheit hätten sich
die planer allerdings genauer ansehen
sollen heutzutage spielen solche
analysen eine wichtige rolle beim
straßenbau
[Musik]
das wissen um die bodenbeschaffenheit
ist enorm wichtig die straße kann noch
so solide gebaut sein aber wenn der
untergrund nicht dafür geeignet ist ist
das ganze konstrukt zum scheitern
verurteilt
die geologische beschaffenheit des
bodens ist der wichtigste faktor ohne
die genaue kenntnis des untergrunds und
der umgebung kann keine langlebige
straße gebaut werden
im volksmund wird der mentor zitternder
berg genannt
das kommt daher dass der berg auf einer
schicht liegt
hier sieht man die überbleibsel eines
früheren erdrutsches die oberfläche mag
insgesamt stabil aussehen doch die
schicht bewirkt dass eine seite des
hügels ständig in bewegung ist besonders
bei starkem regen
jedes jahr arbeitet sich der motor rund
20 cm in richtung castleton vor
[Musik]
die straße selbst wurde auf sandstein
gebaut darunter liegt aber eine schiefer
schicht schiefer ist extrem instabil
besonders im winter
niederschläge sickern durch den
sandstein und machen die schiefer
schicht geradezu flüssig das ist das
problem bei mentor
es dauert nicht lange bis die mentor
wird zum ersten mal aufbricht der hügel
ist schließlich ständig in bewegung
im neunzehnten jahrhundert genügen noch
einfache reparaturmaßnahmen aber dann
wird die straße geteert und die lage
wird noch komplizierter
die einführung des ausfalls macht es
anfangs einfacher die straße
auszubessern steine wurden mit klebrigem
pech gemischt und so entstand eine
ziemlich feste oberfläche aber das
fundament bewegte sich natürlich
trotzdem weiter insofern konnte die
oberfläche noch so gut sein das
grundproblem blieb bestehen
so wird die mentor wird zu einer straße
die sich ständig mit bewegt
im laufe der jahre gab es immer wieder
versuche die straße zu stabilisieren der
aufwändigste erfolgte 1949 nach einem
heftigen erdrutsch wurde eine vertiefung
in den hang gegraben und der untere teil
der straße mit einer kalkstein schicht
verstärkt
das machte alles aber nur noch schlimmer
es war ein eingriff in die natur der
weitere erdrutsche begünstigte außerdem
wurde die oberfläche der straße über
belastet die folge war dass ich die
straße noch stärker bewegte
es war etwa so als hätte man ein extra
gewicht an die falsche seite des
schiefen turms von pisa gehängt alles
wurde nur schlimmer mit dem wissen von
heute hätten sie das nie gemacht
nach weiteren erdrutschen sperren die
behörden 1979 schließlich den mentor ort
für den verkehr
[Musik]
die straße war nicht mehr zu gebrauchen
ab einem gewissen punkt stellte sich die
frage ob es nicht sinnvoller wäre eine
komplett neue straße zu bauen statt die
alte immer weiter zu reparieren
besonders bei der aussicht dass eine
neue straße unterm strich günstiger und
womöglich auch umweltfreundlicher wäre
irgendwann kam der moment an dem man
sich sagte ok die natur hat gewonnen
lasst uns die straße schließen
ein instabiler untergrund ist schlimm
genug wenn sich außerdem auch noch die
oberfläche bewegt wird es für die
straßenbauer richtig kompliziert
eine äußerst ungewöhnliche straße führte
durch diese wüstenlandschaft georg plank
rot ist das ergebnis eines kuriosen
wettrennens
sie war elf kilometer lang und gehörte
früher zur verbindungsstraße zwischen
san diego in kalifornien und phoenix in
arizona
warum wurde sie gebaut und viehbestand
sie den test der zeit
[Musik]
es gab gute gründe warum keine straße
durch diese wüste führte straßen und
wüsten vertragen sich nun mal nicht so
gut
wüsten sind sehr dynamische landschaften
der wind verändert dauernd die
oberflächen alles ist in bewegung mal
geht es aufwärts mal abwärts
darauf eine straße zu bauen ist schon
ziemlich verrückt
bei der otp lenkrad war die einfachste
idee tatsächlich auch die beste
das ziel war auf sehr beweglich im sand
eine straße zu bauen bei einer straße
geht man ja eigentlich davon aus dass
sie stabil ist aber wegen des sams
brauchte man etwas flexiblere die idee
war sehr schlicht aber genau deshalb hat
sie wahrscheinlich funktioniert
1912 ist los angeles die endstation von
amerikas transkontinentalen eisenbahn
das südliche gelegene san diego hingegen
droht im abseits zu bleiben die stadt
ist ohne direkte verkehrsverbindung
richtung osten und wegen der
angrenzenden wüste nur schwer zu
erreichen
das will ein bauunternehmer namens ad
fletcher ändern er verlangt dass sony
ego wenigstens beim straßenbau
berücksichtigt wird dafür sonnt er ein
wettrennen es soll zeigen wie man am
schnellsten von süd kalifornien nach
phoenix arizona fahren kann
[Musik]
fletcher gibt seinem konkurrenten aus l
e 24 stunden vorsprung dann wählt er von
san diego aus eine rote quer durch die
wüste
umfährt vollgas meist muss durch den
sand und erreicht schließlich als erster
das ziel nach nur 19 einhalb stunden
fletcher ist einer dieser in
vergessenheit geratenen amerikanischen
helden er ergriff die initiative und
stellte sich der herausforderung
hey lasst uns eine straße durch die
wüste bauen wie soll das denn gehen mit
holzbohlen das soll funktionieren er
zieht es einfach durch in kalifornien
leben ja angeblich viele verrückte und
das war vielleicht schon immer so aber
ihr ehrgeiz ist einfach bewundernswert
ein schönes beispiel für die kühnheit
der amerikaner eine straße mitten durch
die wüste klar warum nicht kein problem
[Applaus]
1915 drei jahre nachdem er das rennen
gewonnen hat beginnt fletcher
tatsächlich damit den bau einer solchen
straße zu organisieren er beschafft geld
und lässt 13.000 holzkohlen einschiffen
damit baut er eine elf kilometer lange
holzstraße quer durch die wüste
das klingt wie eine idee die ich als
siebenjähriger gehabt haben könnte aber
sie haben das wirklich durchgezogen
13.000 bohlen wurden verlegt eine an der
anderen es klingt unmöglich doch für ad
fletcher war nichts unmöglich
ist da wohl auf diese idee gekommen gold
straßen wurden damals nur für
militärische zwecke gebaut es gab sie
während des amerikanischen bürgerkriegs
und im ersten weltkrieg die briten etwa
haben im belgischen über provisorische
holz straßen gebaut
wahrscheinlich hatte fletcher davon
gehört doch seine straße sollte kein
provisorium werden sie sollte möglichst
lange halten
dass so eine einfache konstruktion
darauf angelegt war länger als ein zwei
jahre zu halten ist schon erstaunlich
[Musik]
fletchers improvisierte straße ist so
erfolgreich dass sie ins offizielle
straßennetz von kalifornien aufgenommen
wird
[Musik]
wenn ich mir damals auf einer landkarte
für die strecke nach san diego die otp
lenkrad ausgeguckt und festgestellt
hatte dass sie buchstäblich auseinander
gelegten planken besteht wäre ich
ziemlich schockiert gewesen mit so was
rechnest du noch nicht
es ist schon sehr eigenartig und
überraschend dass ein paar holz klang
und im sand der sicher bewegt teil einer
echten landstraße werden können
aber wir lernen daraus dass einfache
lösungen manchmal die besten sind
zehn jahre lang ist die bdp lenkrad
stark befahren das holprige holz
konstrukt dient nicht nur als lokale
verbindungsstraße sondern wird auch zur
touristenattraktion
fletchers holzstraße wurde zum erfolg
weil sie etwas völlig neues war ein
regelrechtes abenteuer
die leute wollten sie unbedingt
ausprobieren
bist du schon auf der bank rot gefahren
es ist der wahnsinn das musste jeder mal
erlebt haben
fletcher hat es allen gezeigt
und er verbessert die straße noch die
anfangs schienen artig verlegten reihen
bekommen später auch eine durchgehende
holzoberfläche
[Musik]
das war ein echter fortschritt statt
sein auto mit mühe auf den parallelen
holz rhein zu steuern konnten die
fahrzeuge schließlich über einen
solideren durchgehenden untergrund
fahren
[Musik]
natürlich war das erst einmal eine
verbesserung aber
die probleme blieben die gleichen ein
instabiler untergrund und eine sich
ständig verändernde landschaft
wie stark ist der wind wie bewegt sich
der sand wo ist es am besten wo am
schlimmsten erst wenn du diese fragen
beantwortet hat findest du die lösung
und die lösung besteht elf jahre nach
baubeginn darin die holzbohlen durch
asphalt zu ersetzen 1926 wird die straße
neu gebaut auf einer sandbank
die ingenieure fanden heraus dass der
sand sich an höher gelegenen stellen
viel weniger bewegt als ein tiefer
gelegene die asphaltierte straße wurde
deshalb auf eine künstliche erhebung
gesetzt
die oakley brot hatte direkt auf der
sandschicht gelegen die ständig in
bewegung war
die otp rang rollt wird ab dann nicht
mehr gebraucht
was die plünderer von ihr übrig lassen
holt sich der sand
nichtsdestotrotz az fletcher bewiesen
dass man mit fantasie und
entschlossenheit eine menge erreichen
kann
[Musik]
der straßenbau stellt ingenieure oft vor
kuriose herausforderungen besonders wenn
das thema eigentlich ungeeignet ist im
neunzehnten jahrhundert trotzten
französische straßenbauer die grandeur
ute den bergen regelrecht ab
2005 brächte sich die natur heute lebt
die straße verlassen da
die gurgel route wurde
verständlicherweise gesperrt die straße
war einfach zu gefährlich geworden was
wird jetzt daraus soll sie verbreitert
und mit seilen gesichert werden
oder lassen wir sie in ruhe und bewahren
uns die romantische erinnerung an ein
außergewöhnliches beispiel früher
ingenieurskunst
ich denke letztere sollten wir tun
[Musik]
die mentoren in nordengland rutschte
über die jahrzehnte unaufhaltsam den
berghang hinab auch sie musste gesperrt
werden und zwar schon 1979
[Musik]
georg plank wort im südwesten der usa
hat erstaunlicherweise bewiesen dass der
am wenigsten geeignete untergrund am
ende gar nicht so problematisch ist wer
alle denken heute verläuft dort ein
asphaltierter highway
[Musik]
und fletcher fletcher hat san diego mit
arizona verbunden vielleicht wäre die
region sonst nie so erschlossen worden
wie sie es heute ist
als einziges dieser projekte ist allein
die straße der 52 tunnel in italien noch
halbwegs intakt nachdem sie 60 jahre
lang in vergessenheit geraten war wurde
sie in den 70er jahren wiederentdeckt
freiwillige begannen die tunnel von
geröll freizuräumen und reparierten die
wege
die strecke ist ein beliebtes ziel für
wanderer und kletterer die nicht nur die
spektakuläre aussicht genießen sondern
auch jene arbeiter gedenken die hier
unter schwierigsten umständen
unglaubliches geleistet haben
erst lange nach dem krieg haben sich die
menschen darauf besonnen welch
unglaubliche konstruktions leistung in
dieser straße steckt
und sie können hier immer noch sehen
welche opfer ihre vorfahren im ersten
weltkrieg auf sich nahmen und ihrer
leistung gedenken
die erbacher straße da 52 tunnel in
italien setzten nicht nur sich selbst
ein denkmal sondern einen straßenbauern
der letzten zwei jahrhunderte
von ed fletchers holzstraße durch die
wüste im amerikanischen südwesten über
die spektakuläre rote kongo lee in
frankreich bis zur wieder und wieder
erneuerten mentor roth in nordengland
für sie alle gilt das motto der
italiener die namen derer die großes
vollbringen werden für immer in
erinnerung bleiben
[Musik]